al'approche des fêtes de noël les
supermarchés et grandes enseignes
préparent leurs vitrines pour donner
l'envié d'acheter mais cet hiver
l'association plaisir en transition
propose le défi zéro déchet en réduisant
d'abord sa consommation
globalement on est une vingtaine de
famille à s'être associé et
dans le même but de réduire nos déchets
donc un peu changé sa consommation pour
alléger nos poubelles qui font 400 kg
normalement à l'année en moyenne donc le
but c'est de réduire de 30% calendrier
de l'avent avec des rouleaux de papier
toilette ou encore des sapins sans
épines et recyclables les bonnes idées
fusent lors des ateliers
selon l'ademe chaque personne jette plus
d'un kilo de déchets par jour
l'objectif de l'association est donc
d'abord de sensibiliser au quotidien le
zéro déchet c'est pas une mode c'est un
mode de vifs
c'est tout simplement de faire attention
d'être consom'acteurs de faire attention
à ce qu'on consomme 2
de trouver des alternatives à mener de
manière ludique et intelligente ce défi
zéro déchet pour noël inclut les grands
comme les petits
avec la maman pour les mouchoirs de la
check une fois il ya quatre ans les
trois quilles à noël zéro déchet je suis
venu ce matin un petit peu pour pour
voir comment je peux réduire les déchets
pour noël notamment si m'intéresserait
c'est de faire en fait un sapin de noël
0 des chefs valoriser les cadeaux qui ne
sont pas matérielle est une des
solutions zéro déchet la hotte du père
noël promet d'être écolo en 2017